your GQ you're going to do all of the
cool stuff I don't know why I'm doing
that we're all going to have footage
where it does that and stuff and I'm
here
I'm sorry Hi GQ I'm more polter this is
my life in sneakers
[Music]
my passion for sneakers I guess it
started in a kind of multi-faceted way I
have an older brother called Ed has
always been cooler than me and I was
always just kind of chasing what my
brother was wearing and doing and he was
always really into his Nike sneakers you
know more than anything else and then I
think it was also influenced by the
music I was listening to so a lot of UK
and US hip-hop white Air Force Ones that
I guess I associated with us hip-hop Air
Max 95s and 97s that are more kind of
associated with UK hip-hop one of my
favorite shows growing up as a kid was
Fresh Prince of Bel-Air and I don't
think her character has ever had a
better array of sneakers than will in
the Fresh Prince the sneaker culture
around me was very much like informed by
playing football in the street and then
when it came to like wearing sort of a
formal shoe to me that was just like an
all-white Air Force One the first Nike
that I would have bought for the purpose
of like not playing football and like
wearing and like protecting and taking
care of was probably an Air Max One I
want to say it was like orange and red
with white it was quite out there like
more out there than maybe I am these
days with some of my shoes you know I
have a uh Jordan one called Jordan one
Chicago's I bought them in Chicago with
my friend Julian Sergi they're a shoe
that I associate with all the times that
we've spent eating food together and
going sneaker shopping and every time I
wear them I think of him I tried for the
longest time to find a Jordan 6 Infrared
and I wanted to get it because I went to
see Watch the Throne live and Jay-Z was
wearing a Jordan six infrared and I
thought it was the coolest shoe I've
ever seen it's probably one of my
favorite shoes of all time this is
before like we were reselling days
before it was all available online as
easily as it is now you had to kind of
go physically crate digging for it I
don't really have a connect for sneakers
like Nike have always been incredibly
good to me I'm My Own plug so if you're
if you're watching this and you are a
sneaker connect give me a shout
[Music]
this is probably the most sentimental
shoe that I have a Nike Air Force One
Detroit film and El Cappy El Cappy is an
amazing artist in Detroit and I did a
film called Detroit and they designed
this shoe for me and my classmates and
it's just so special it's something I'd
never wear I keep this one in a perspex
box kind of see it more as a piece of
art there's like a mural if you like of
the Detroit Rebellion on the outside of
the shoe and then Detroit kind of across
the toe I just love it so much I'm
really proud to be a part of the movie
and this is a really lovely bit of
memorabilia that I have from from that
experience
these are the Nike Air Max One OG
anniversary edition these shoes right
here are going in the classics category
these are a little bit worn these have
had some wear oh there's a scuff right
there doing my head in I wore these to
Tiny tempers what we wear show in London
I believe it was their first showing and
Nike actually gave me these shoes to
celebrate Air Max day I find Air Max
ones just like really wearable you can
kind of dress them up dress them down
I'll often wear these with a jean like a
blue jean but then really any kind of
like blue trouser or pant depending on
what side of the Atlantic you're on I've
started saying pants and my my London
mates uh get onto me for that I mean
don't wear your underwear in these
necessarily well it will do I don't know
whatever you want to do I don't do that
personally but yeah a jean or a blue
trouser is how I tend to wear these I
love these shoes
this is the Nike SB dunk High Mama fuku
shoe I'm putting this in the special
collaboration category mama fuku is my
favorite restaurant chain in the world
it's headed up by the amazing David
Chang I didn't even know they created
this shoe and my brother uh bought it
for me one Christmas it's not in my size
so it is purely a display shoe it's
really nice to have like kind of two of
my passions which are food and shoes
combined and they're made out of cakes
you can eat another you can't eat them
never been worn so they're lickable
talented designer category these have
some real sentimental value to me I wore
these red Louis Vuitton sneakers to the
Kim Jones Louis Vuitton Supreme show in
Paris so it's really cool to see you
know a collaboration between a giant and
streetwear and a giant fashion house
like Louis Vuitton these are the Nike
Air Max 360 High designed by Kim Jones
and you notice that Kim Jones is in the
kind of traditional Nike font there it's
the first time they ever allowed that to
happen I just think Kim's such a
talented designer and he's done some
really special things with Nike and it's
got yeah a little Nike smiley face which
is kind of cool too
[Music]
these are the Nike craft Tom sacks shoes
this probably goes into the best gift
category these were given to me by my
agent Andrew it was around the time of
my 30th birthday but I think it was like
a end of year kind of Christmas present
type thing incredibly thoughtful of him
he's a sneakerhead as well these have
actually never been worn only got them a
couple of months ago I don't even know
if I will wear them when you've got gum
Sole and then also this bit of black it
is tempting to wear them if they were
like a paler tone or like white at the
bottom they're not getting worn I'm too
scared but that that is encouraging
there's a little bit of guard there do
you know what I mean
I think these shoes go in the legendary
category I don't know what they're worth
they're around two thousand six hundred
dollars are they really well you sell
them though no I'm not selling them for
love no money they're from the 10
collection designed by Virgil ablo
between off-white and Nike the Classic
Air Force One but deconstructed in the
way that you know is so kind of iconic
with Virgil they are
in a case safe and sound I did wear them
once or maybe twice I don't anymore and
I won't I don't think I think the Air
Force One is probably my favorite
silhouette for a Nike shoe everything
about its structure and its layout is
kind of perfect and it's just like the
ultimate sneaker really I love these
shoes so much
if there's one shoe that I really do
want it's the Jordan 4 sale that Virgil
ablo designed and he actually made a
number of pairs available at auction to
raise money for the black curriculum
which is an amazing organization an
organization that Virgil was an
ambassador of
[Music]
I want you to craft your top five that
you have here now okay Troy
you know this one's magical I'll do the
kittens
whoa two we've got to go
that's going just for now
this is not fun
I think these are my top three right
here
oh my God
now I've got like I've got like a pair
two right feet
all right and now final one out
[Music]
this one right here my number one
what is next for me on my shoe Journey
add to my collection of ones a little
bit because I love Jordan Ones my
collection is pretty big but I tried to
kind of consolidate it a little bit
recently and I built uh this is the
nerdiest thing I've ever done custom
made a shelving unit for my shoes I
thought I'd ordered it pre-built and
then just a bunch of like wooden tiles
showed up and then I had to kind of
build it now it's kind of maybe that my
favorite piece of like Furniture in my
house because it it houses my favorite
things which are my shoes GQ thank you
so much thank you for watching this
thank you for letting me do this it was
so cool take care